[Music]
we're looking at using Google clouds
natural language processing for
understanding health taxonomy in work
you do internally government public
published regulatory analysis and
research done by life scientists groups
insurances the concept being we wanted
to very quickly be able to read large
amounts of documents saved in
traditional file formats like PDFs text
HTML pages if you think of the
organizational knowledge sprawl you
would see at an enterprise healthcare
organization you have critical work
that's been done and only lives in one
workstation so the context for this
presentation my name is Alex well thing
I am a consultant atman app it's a group
with Inman at Phelps and Philips it's a
legal regulatory policy group our
clientele covers everything from life
sciences state federal government's
insurance places and we've got
extraordinary depth of expertise in
areas like Medicaid I don't have any of
that
I came over a year ago from a pulsing
tech startup where we were making
interactive games inside of articles we
were being able to scrape the content on
the page and make an interactive I
wanted to bring cutting-edge development
using things like the NLP API to solve
this very very simple but understanding
how complex the problem can get of
connecting our documents together so
we'll walk through what we've done there
but if you want to be able to do
something like this for yourself at your
organization
we took a prototyping and tooling
approach to this project
what we built isn't live yet it's not
something that's a model that we've
deployed and count as a production
implementation of natural language
understanding in healthcare we didn't do
that instead we've built something that
we can start up and destroy in 30
minutes and extract the business value
we need from it when you think about the
organizational resources you need to
bring something like this to market we
were able to save a lot of effort there
and avoid a lot of regulatory concern
around what we're doing with this
information because it's a very
temporary analysis so if you want to be
able to follow along create a new
project in Google cloud platform I'll
show you how to start up the Google
cloud engine and load in a a web app
where you get display your final results
as well as do the actual calls so a
little further context around our
product our client base wanted access to
our knowledge collective we've done work
for public facing organizations like our
WJ Commonwealth ship at the same time
we've done a lot of internal work just
to keep our expertise up to date where
we do 50 state trackers looking at
telehealth policies across the country
we put all of this available to our
clients starting January 1 2018 we had
about a four or five month ramp time
since I joined - official launch so if
you think of the timing of this
development we started NLP exploration
in October 2017 we're still working on
it today but we're really excited about
where we can move it forward the initial
concept we wanted to do though it was
very simply this is a piece of content
we've written this is an analysis of a
regulatory summary the government just
released since 2000 pages we are going
to do the hard work of having our
lawyers read through diligently analyze
that work
it's my job on the web front to connect
all of that information they wrote and
looked at effectively to all of our
other sources of information and what
I'm not going to do is ask a partner at
the firm to look at a 300 word keyword
list and here are the other 25 examples
of ones that have used these keywords
does this make sense it was kind of a we
realized very quickly that wasn't going
to be the successful approach so I
wanted to be able to empower them to
understand how our keyword strategy was
working but also for them as subject
matter experts to guide where we were
going with our strategy in that regard
so we want Bill share our tool with
partners and authors and finally I want
to reach extraordinary depths of
accuracy and understanding of our source
material it would be very easy for us to
categorize our work into 10 general
buckets this is Medicaid this is life
sciences work but if we could understand
hundreds of entities in our documents
and have a salient connected to each of
those the more content we build the less
likely we are to get lost along the way
and to lose investment we've already
made in in previous work it helps tell
their story if we've got a really good
data approach in that last box so here's
the the breakdown for the tech demo we
use the command line interface to
extract out text from PDFs this is PDF
to text dot pi it's a pretty simple
script we then transfer the text
documents to Google Cloud storage where
you very efficiently can do calls to the
natural language API and it's all
in-house we want to be able to keep this
very much in the Google cloud platform
then we call the ml once we have that
output it's going to give us a JSON
it's gonna save the JSON into the Google
cloud and Google compute engine and
we're focusing specifically on analyze
entities
I'll show you analyze sentiment and
analyze categories as well but we really
got the most value out of using analyze
entities option within natural language
so we would then want to be able to
deploy for end-users to be able to view
the results of what we did we would want
to be able to share in a green check
mark HTTP location what it is we were
just looking at so I'll show you two
examples in that regard one is a further
built out CMS integration with our
natural language processing which is a
user interface using ghost and firebase
where users are able to log in and do
this whole process themselves and then
I'll also show you how to launch it in a
simpler version on hex au which I don't
know if there's any developers who run
their blog on github but github pages
and hexo integration is a very common
way of hosting just posting your
information so that's we're aiming for
just posting the information and we do
look at a wide range of document sizes
and I'll give you a little bit of
context around where there's some
challenges there I want to give this
boilerplate a really good highlight
because it's an it's an amazing
organization that I've looped into
coming from a very tech startup
background II context I would say
looking around this conference there
aren't many organizations that have the
depth of legal expertise in the
healthcare space and what I would most
love to get out of this year's
attendance is for ten of my colleagues
to want to come are experts in data
analytics who help provider systems you
know take looks at their entire
collection of data and we've got sharing
projects in LA County
I would love for this tech community to
help bridge the gap with subject matter
experts further and for those of you who
are maybe extremely on the tech side and
are looking for partners on the legal
and regulatory consulting side that's
where I would really say I'm not your
guy I would love to introduce you to my
colleagues so very quickly
I'd like to share a bit about our
approach towards investing into NLP Nai
because this is a lean team insights and
manat health the publication that I'm a
part of consists of a senior director
who oversees the editorial vision we
have two senior managers who help with
the production of the content the
working relationships as a clients and I
manage the front end eye mantle of the
publication of the information the
things that go on the site and our
budgets rather limited so I still have
very real objectives I want to
accomplish at our organization at the
same time I know where we're trying to
get to I know what our clients would
like from us I know what our
organization would like to bring to the
table and sharing information when
you're at a conference like this there
is a there's an opinionated stance on
open and democratized web that needs to
be shared and advocated for these two
examples I've I've thrown up on the
screen are two kind of disparate cases
cited from EFS the first being the
Freedom of Information Act fine of the
year someone wanted to know information
about sexual assault in Texas prisons
it's the type of information that's a
critical health question for our country
and there are advocates and data
scientists out there who spend hours of
their free time writing into government
organizations asking for information
it was gonna cost a million dollars just
for the labor of scanning in the
documents to be able to complete this
foi a that is a very real example of the
cost for access to this information and
the opportunity we have bringing NLP
into marketplace I didn't get anything
that was that sophisticated but I knew
we wanted to play in the space already
we were ready and the technology is
already available that myself is not an
expert developer can put us on the right
path for considerations of how to
intelligently bring this technology to
market the second example is another
another extreme where you have to
consider the full severity of the work
you can do as developers who say to
scientists the models you make if you
want to bring something to production
it can't be racist this letter is 42
organizations that penned to axon which
is a provider of law enforcement
equipment they were looking at bringing
to market or beginning research after
putting together an AI Ethics Board into
facial recognition technologies the
people who would be most affected by
these technologies you work on have to
be a part of the process from the very
start of the development consideration
of the idea through the working models
final sign-off this I believe is one of
the only ways we're going to
successfully get as a collective to a
place where we feel very confident and
safe with the models were building
more practically think about what your
day-to-day work life is like when you're
thinking of the two options of where you
can go with data science and building
models for AI I'd encourage you to check
out obviously the other sessions that
are deep in this space but you you see
the work that you can be doing the
experimentation the testing the
iterations on this model we want to be
in this middle bucket we want to be
working as a group all together
experimenting writing scientific papers
analyzing it and feeling comfortable
with the security we've brought of
course there is still closed source
development I'm not saying that your
organization's not going to have a
proprietary take on a model that Google
is made but I think it increasingly
unlikely that your internal organization
is going to be trying to build the
natural language API you want to build
the application that uses it you want to
be able to train your own models for
something like that
but we're not going to want to be in
this left bucket where you as a
developer or data scientist your team no
matter how well constructed well
developed you don't want to be standing
out isolated you don't want to be
bringing to market production models and
that haven't been proved by the
community at large we want a stringent
testing system and these questions
weighed really heavy on us when we are
looking at NLP even for just analyzing
our own writing and regulatory work so
here's the question
you've got these two options I would
love out of this group because I've kind
of seen the the job titles and
organizations who are represented here
if I could get a quick close your eyes
and raise your hands for either the
first or second I would be fascinated to
know for my own no knowledge so quick
eyes close raise your hand if our first
option is we're not going to be able to
get there right now you're not going to
be able to hit production because the
regulation the technical obstacles it's
not clear enough we are not in a safe
space to be able to launch or we're in
the bomb's
question we're right now you could go
home after this conference and start a
project on Monday work with stakeholders
diligently build a new tool that you
could bring to market in your company by
the end of the year that would safely
having consideration the second and I
apologize there's one person who'd close
their eyes and raise their hand now we
can ask the question all right close
your eyes
raise your hand for one and second
wonderful that that's really exciting to
see it's exciting to see that you know
probably 70% of the room was
enthusiastic about our second option
truth is I feel like whichever you pick
is going to be the route you go this
slide on the right some of you might
recognize it this is a produced from our
US Senate it's an analysis of the
solutions we could take to prevent why
to take a crisis what I love about this
is on the left hand on your y-axis
that's months to implement data data
expansion it's gonna take us 48 months
to get there but it gives us the highest
performance reliability standards
against a y2k bug tensorflow
came out
last year you think of the context
around the development of our space and
it's not just software development it's
the architecture it's the hardware that
you run your models and the networking
that you're running it on this seems
irrelevant but we will equally have
similar lack of understanding when we
look back on our current analysis of AI
today where we really missed the mark on
some things but I do like just to rely
on the experts I'm not going to be
making any of this up myself I'm not a
leader in machine learning and
artificial intelligence I'm a user I'm
someone who practically has day-to-day
tasks I want to get done and I am
grateful to be in a space where leaders
like Faye Faye Lee are carving out this
space for us for us to be able to do our
work
so from 2017 during her session these
were four principle components for
democratizing AI that are essential for
if we go back to stakeholder involvement
you look at the axon example and this is
a perfect chance to consider whether or
not we're really looking at a
democratized AI scenario making sure
everybody who would be impacted by an
artificial intelligent solution has
access to computing computing resources
to test it has access to training and
resources so that they themselves can
become the talent that works on these
projects making sure the algorithms and
the data that you're using and bringing
to market is accessible to a scientific
and open community is gonna make this
slide a lot more fun I've been playing
in the bottom left-hand corner where our
budgets will range from you know tens of
dollars I look at you know
if I can spend less than $100 and
deliver you some sort of business value
I only have to save someone 10 minutes
to make back that hundred hundred
dollars so I look at big opportunities
to carve out save time savings and
that's prototyping tools it's not going
to be something that can live forever
it's gonna have instabilities that there
are clear spots where that wasn't built
out because it wasn't supposed to be we
don't want to spend our developers time
working on something that's not going to
come to market and practically my
organization doesn't have a need for a
enterprise natural language processing
tool we got a question we want to answer
an AI helped us do it this top right
corner though I think we're all
passionate about getting there the
potential impact of bringing to market a
IOT healthcare device that is able to
consistently monitor your glucose levels
and it works even when the power goes
off and the Internet's gone and it's
able to help predict critical failures
of your health we all know we want to be
making new markets and changing people's
lives with AI but the risks around that
are scary I would say for for developers
we've got some concerns but primarily
for investors there's maybe 10 billion
dollars a year in the u.s. pouring into
AI research and I think I think you
could short that I think you could
safely say 10 xìng that AI research
would still be a fair safe investment
you clearly haven't seen it though and
until some of those regulatory legal
concerns get worked through and resolved
and their safe space to play and bring
to market then maybe we continue working
on prototyping tools and then bring them
to internal tools and continue to
develop a culture
that knows how to use AI applications
wants to build these things and have
tested it rigorously you don't want your
first one to be the one that goes to
market so this there's a lot on this
slide and I apologize let's start with
the most interesting information this is
a paper I believe this was a Google team
that they presented initially in
February and it won a bunch of awards in
June obfuscated gradients give a false
sense of security
circumventing defenses to adversarial
examples that's frightening I feel at
the conference they won best
presentation there were eight proclaimed
secure white box algorithms and this
took them all down this came out in
March tensor flow 1.0 which most data
science it not that there's not other
models like that it's not like you can't
use Kerris it's not like there's not HQ
o dot AI but tensor flow is a really
good example you look at the forks
there's clearly interest that's not
enough time in between these two events
happening for me to feel confident yet
the other side of this is the context is
the you know thing that's weighing us
down in this consideration we got a Tim
berners-lee in 1989 this is I you know I
don't think it makes sense to start a
conversation about open web before that
and then we have the cost estimates for
that y2k bug
it looks like antenna might be at 195
million if y2k doesn't go well and those
figures seem extreme and they seem goofy
now but they didn't at the time I feel
like we are going to have similarly
goofy not goofy but misunderstandings
about where we are in the cycle as we
see in 1999
and this last component just elaborates
on the idea of investing in tools the
left framework I would highly encourage
you if honestly if there's anything you
took away out of this development talk
it would be that framework
it wasn't even originally intended for
developers it's the framework for
strategic sustainable development came
out of a group in Sweden in the early
90s
it's about sustainability in the world
and it really drills it down into a
systems level if we talk about this
system of AI development and healthcare
that would include all of the algorithms
the talent pool the hardware that's
available for you to run it in the end
devices the systems that subscribe to it
the entire ecosystem everything
everything that you touch it's very hard
to change that and it's a collective
effort to make changes to the system but
making tools is easy and tools are what
we use to take action in our day-to-day
jobs if we've got better tools to do the
work that we want to accomplish and
there's tangible benefits in our ability
to execute the organization's strategy
do your job better do your job easier
thanks to the tools now you can execute
your strategy and if we align our
strategy with some smart goals that
feeds all the way up to a great system
but the main thing that I can say that
we're focusing on right now is making
sure we've got talent who we feel
comfortable working with and we are
we've got a similar dialogue around
these tools we want to test a lot of
platforms and services I'm here at
Google's presentation but I would love
to run similar experiments across the
enterprise solutions here there is a
certain amount of you don't want to
factor your efforts too much and I've
been very happy in the ecosystem I
operate in I do all of our work in
Google cloud platform but when you want
to evaluate the platforms
and your product should still deliver
business value if your manager comes up
and asked table I see these API calls
what what is this there should be
something that you're trying to get out
of it one of the additional components
of framework for strategic system
development is bat casting understanding
where you want to arrive and where you
are today and understanding what steps
it what you would be taking to get to
that eventual end goal as opposed to
forecasting saying historically here's
what we've done based off of those
projections we project we will get here
this is the opposite we know if we want
to get to market we are going to need a
great development team that's fully
bought in and it's well staffed we need
stakeholder buy-in from the community
you need the patients who are going to
be affected by your product to know
about it from the get-go from the first
time you had the idea to use AI to
better analyze rhythmic patterns of the
heart you should probably talk to some
heart heart patients and find out about
their experiences having regulations in
place would help having very clear
guidance in that space and that's going
to be a combination from the government
getting involved as well as from the
tech side being leaders and advocates
cloud-first architecture for data I
think that makes sense we're at Google
next and the ability to run on device
and in cloud computation for the results
I do think I do think mentioning on
device calculations is important one of
the really interesting examples is a
tensor flow j/s but I think
fundamentally being able to do localized
calculations is extremely helpful so I
want to pivot now this is the switch
over to prac
here's what the work looks like so how
done analyze hundreds of pages I'll give
you a couple slides on our consideration
the development process and then we'll
switch over to the live demo um this is
just a consideration pyramid for when
you are taking on a project like this
who are you going to be presenting this
to if you are sharing the work you're
doing with this with a development team
lead for example someone who's very
interested in the house and wise this
works but wouldn't be concerned about
the appearances maybe you don't need to
worry about throwing up during the
prototype development a firewall that
secures all of this within your own
internal network or you don't need HTTPS
access and it's just going to show up as
a nice beautiful IP address that they
know you could deploy to a front end if
you want it on the other hand if you're
going to be taking this work and you're
gonna spend four or five hours building
something that you feel really
comfortable and confident in and you're
going to be sharing it with senior
executives in the finance side who
really don't have an interest in the
house and the whys of launching a server
in compute engine and why that might not
be in it it's not a necessary expense or
time sink but it looks pretty having the
green checkmark in a nice formatted URL
does help get the point across clearer
and if that's all the amount of lift you
need to do to go from they don't
understand it at all to the idea clicks
I see where this would help us and we
would want to do more of this or even
better they see it and they've got their
own ideas of I would I would love
something like this to solve this
problem then that's a fruitful
conversation and then it's worth going
ahead and adding in I've given you you
can just throw in our start bot you can
get a domain name for
less than fifty cents from chief named
comm and between those two you've got
really no excuse for not to show up as
an HTTP product next is the actual
computations that we used simple enough
we did a 16-point for a for instance 350
gigs of standard memory on it important
details that we've got I went ahead and
allowed full access to the cloud API so
you're still going to need to enable the
natural language API once you get into
the platform you've got your project but
you also want make sure you allow
traffic and below this setting set a
static IP address for this engine for
external use because that way you can
connect it hex own ghosts were the two
CMS's we use when looking at displaying
our information ghost is a startup that
has really that they've committed
themselves to being a nonprofit entity
and they've been working on a really
great publishing platform that I've been
satisfied to use and/or bring to market
for an internal blog so you've got the
directions for ghost I would highlight
that you need to use like a node v6 or
v8 it doesn't support ten or nine that's
the one we added in firebase I've shared
the code for that but I haven't cleaned
it up for you in a really really
presentable way because your development
team knows how to do this you could give
them these instructions and say you
bring them your idea here's the
documents we would like to categorize
and organize they would know how to be
able to do the firebase but I have
shared the example as well and on the
hexer side this is just dead simple to
use you're able to generate all of your
static files in a second 450
or so so hexa is a really easy example
to be able to get something up and
moving and what's interesting is you can
do all if you're like user-interface
things like making I could source to
this team right here if each of you
would like a document analyzed just put
it into ghost tagged it with what you
think you would like it to what should
be and then I could export all of that
and import it into Excel
so they complement each other really
well as far as to CMS's just to be able
to share the info so here are very
helpful instructions on the top one is
how to deploy ghost on GCP middle one is
link to where the firebase theme one
other example all throughout there on
this is a when we did the ghost
integration to be able to make this call
we didn't do any editing on the backend
this is on a theme level editing only
improvement so I I kind of throw a curve
ball at the development team and I'd
like to give a shout-out to Brayden
Kelly he's a father now and helped us
bring to market the firebase example
really took the idea and ran with it and
worked around challenges that your team
wouldn't need you wouldn't need to
introduce these challenges to your
product but we had them in ours and
finally uh the bottom one is where all
the analyze entities the natural
language API is located so let's go
ahead and hop over to the tech demo and
oh wow I apologize the first screen you
see isn't a Google product that is a
deployment engine I know the last slide
we left on said let's talk about how to
prep the documents but I'd like to first
share with you this is the front end
example of ghost so
I would like to find a document to
analyze I'm going to quickly login to
now let's say we want to analyze this
text document we did on houseplants to
consider white house recisions package
CMS says no to lifetime limits for
Medicaid coverage I'm going to come over
to here and this is all just text input
but for the command-line interface here
we've added in content types
all this information is stored in
firestore so if I wanted to then go and
edit the content type or add in new key
topics it's as simple as going to my
firebase site and adding that into the
catalog so here I'm indicating what I
initially think this document would be
about I think it's insurance and
marketplaces fraud and abuse
I provide a little bit of additional
info in the top line just for visibility
on the front end and finally let's take
this is a six page document so it's not
too bad we've pasted all the information
in there's nothing going on so we get
our spinning wheel and I've timed it it
can be everywhere from under a minute
for something small to taking several
minutes for larger-scale content what I
think is actually super helpful oh did
it pass great so let's see what we got
this spits out so here here here's what
we submitted and then down here we have
what we wanted so if I was empowering a
you know a partner or a consultant at
our
sation I could first give them this
resource here's the URL to go to if they
take the first step of putting in their
information here then from my end I can
take what they've shared and bring it to
market on the product or I can start a
meaningful conversation with this
subject expert who put the work together
and I can ask him which of these on the
front page would make sense to tag your
content for and we can scroll through
just for a little bit of clarity the two
items we're seeing on this screen you
have salience which is really actually
that's what I found the most helpful
salience is the importance of that word
within the entire document you're able
to add up count as well but and I will
say the count gets filtered out very
nicely also some additional info that I
think has been actually very helpful and
and illuminating this is the sentiment
analysis and it we printed out basically
in a byline example I feel like a
someone who's good at text manipulation
would clean up some of this before it
goes in I wouldn't keep in see page 5
for coverage but let me find an
interesting sentence here I've genuinely
found unique insights about the
regulatory analysis that's gotten
published or about research based on
these and this feature specifically so
I've sumed in here let's look at this
very positive one other measures include
research on new non-addictive pain
medications loan repayment for Sud
providers and the creation of
comprehensive opioid recovery centers
intended to serve as treatment models
that's a pretty positive sentence
there's a lot of loaded information that
you understand why it would flag that's
fine for our specific coverage this is
something we wrote I think where it's
even more interesting is when you see
something like this point nine positive
green in a published piece of government
regulation or a announcement of upcoming
regulation because regulations not
particularly emotional it's not supposed
to have these flowery languages and if I
have time I can share a specific example
of one we found uniquely passionate
advocacy within one line and looking at
the time I'm going to now pivot over to
showing you how to do
lastly they've got categories as well
I'm just showing this to you to show it
hasn't gotten there yet the the
categories API is fantastic if you have
broad ranges of content if you're
specifically within one section like law
and government or healthcare it might
not be as informative for you because I
kind of knew our content was health care
in law related I that that didn't help
narrow it down for me so who wants to
see it in the council side well let's
find a good little workspace so really
quickly let me show you these are
examples of the different web apps we've
used to deploy the info I think all
these are kind of accessible in one
state or another making a brand new heck
so post or site is as easy as sudo heck
so in it let's call this GCP live and
it's going to go ahead and pull in all
the info I need to have a working web
app well that runs now I almost regret
even giving it the option to do so let's
go and look at some of the text
documents
in my Google Cloud storage
I'll show you the final result of what
we've done so you have first final JSON
outputs if you look at the file sizes
it's substantial in the sense of that
for a JSON things reaching 1/2 Meg 1 Meg
plus it is a lot of information so
realize that each of these is going to
seem unnecessarily large this is this
what it looks like at the outset you you
really do need to filter down into it to
extract the information but let me take
my cue to here's the text output I would
like to show you PDF to text all the way
through and I feel like I can get there
all right so let's let's knock this out
I've got cue to content in a zip in the
cloud so let's
do we get it yeah we did
you know instead of me trying to live
code that specific function of it what
I'm going to do is show you kind of cool
fancy final product of what our analysis
was I've shared I've got the
instructions I in later slides that we
didn't get to on how to actually do the
the PDF to text it's super simple but I
am really interested in sharing what
this final output looked like this is 25
of our most recent publications that we
took a look at and the final output of
that JSON I just exported out to tableau
and what you're seeing on the left on
the y-axis is salience per entity and on
the left on the x-axis our keywords I'm
having to zoom in a lot to even get to a
point where the key words aren't so
spread out because across 25 documents
we would have tens of thousands of
entities generated and it listed those
all the way across but let's keep
zooming in to see what some of these
look like and all of a sudden I'm able
to start getting some real insight into
connections between documents from a
source like this so for example CMS was
point zero one four one importance to
this analysis on the new payment model
versus something like this that came in
at point one three eight five and I know
all of these documents have info related
to CMS that reached a critical mass to
categorize it in here
Whitehouse came up in this group of five
we can view each individually with that
being said here are the last slides in
30 seconds here's that here's an initial
result here's an initial result here is
the video of me walking it through on
ghost
and here is the final wrap-up slide of
what we came into it with and what we
left with it's been a really exciting
project and if I've got 15 seconds left
I just have to thank countlessly
the the team that helps support this
work the senior leadership as well as
Lauren Thomas my fiance for helping me
walk through the deck and get here today
thank you so much for your time as well
[Applause]
[Music]